-Welcome back, everybody!
Welcome back.
Here at "The Tonight Show,"
we love songs
and we especially love songs
written by our audience members
in under an hour.
It is time for Battle
of the Instant Songwriters.
Here we go.
-♪ Singing a song,
and I'm singing a song ♪
♪ And I'm writing a song
about another song ♪
-Welcome to Battle
of the Instant Songwriters.
Before the show, we went
through our great audience
and picked out two people who
said that they were musicians.
We gave them each
a made-up song title
and gave them an hour
to write an original song
based on that title.
Here's a shot of them practicing
backstage a minute ago.
There they are.
Let's see what they come up with
and meet them right now.
Come on over, guys. Welcome!
-♪ Singing a song,
and I'm singing a song ♪
-Thank you for being here.
Thank you for being here.
-♪ About another song ♪
-Welcome to the show.
Let's start with you.
Contestant number one,
what is your name
and where are you from?
-My name is Rachel Rose.
I'm from Fairfield, Connecticut.
-Rachel Rose!
Welcome to the show!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thank you for doing this.
What was the title of the song
that you were given?
-I Think This Airbnb
is Haunted."
-Ooh. Ooh, that's topical.
We're about to enter
spooky season
if we haven't entered it
already.
Do you think we're in
spooky season now or...?
-Absolutely. I do.
-Yeah. Me too.
-What instrument?
I'm assuming the guitar, right?
-Yes, the guitar.
-I saw you playing that.
That's right. Okay. Very good.
Why don't you get over
and get set
and I will introduce you --
Yeah.
Get in the zone and get ready.
Rachel Rose right there.
[ Cheers and applause ]
"I Think This Airbnb
is Haunted."
And now, ladies and gentlemen,
here to perform
the world premiere
of the soon-to-be classic
"I Think This Airbnb
is Haunted,"
it's Rachel Rose.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
♪ My little B&B ♪
♪ Live by undead company ♪
♪ A ghostly welcome
I received that stay ♪
♪ I can't be sure,
but if I'm honest ♪
♪ I think this B&B is haunted ♪
♪ Keep my refund,
I don't want it, no way ♪
[ Laughter ]
♪ When I got there,
I felt tricked ♪
♪ 'Cause the door key code
said six, six, six ♪
♪ Right then
it should have clicked ♪
♪ What was in store ♪
♪ Old pictures
hung along the walls ♪
♪ Their eyes followed me
down the halls ♪
♪ I swear I heard them
calling out my name ♪
♪ The bedroom
had the strangest smell ♪
♪ Of dusty drapes and 5 Chanel ♪
♪ I knew I wasn't alone,
I could tell ♪
♪ The terms of service
never mentioned this ♪
♪ When a cold hand went
and grabbed my wrist ♪
♪ I didn't think I'd need
an exorcist today ♪
♪ I think this Airbnb
is haunted ♪
♪ Keep my refund,
I don't want it ♪
♪ With a one-star review ♪
♪ Hope it'll be a clue ♪
♪ To stay away ♪
[ Laughter ]
♪ I know I should have gone
with my Homestay today ♪
-Wow! My God!
[ Cheers and applause ]
That was good!
Give it up for Rachel Rose
right there! Come on!
What an incredible,
beautiful voice.
Oh, my gosh. And funny, too.
Let's meet
contestant number two.
Yeah, you're nervous. Alright.
You're like, "Wait. People
can really sing here?" Yeah.
What is your name
and where are you from?
-My name is Josh Bolin.
I'm originally from
Canton, Ohio, but I live here.
-Hey. We love Canton, Ohio.
How are you doing?
Thanks for being here, Josh.
Josh, tell everyone
what your song title is.
-It's called "Taylor, Kelce,
and Me Makes Three."
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Oh, interesting.
What instrument
will you be playing?
-Guitar, as well.
-Wow. That's pretty fun.
Why don't you go and get up
there and get ready to perform?
It's a big deal.
This could be a big hit song.
Yeah.
Alright. Here we go.
Ladies and gentlemen,
get ready for the world premiere
of "Taylor, Kelce, and Me
Make Three" by Josh Bolin.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-♪ Sat down to watch
the Chiefs play Chicago ♪
♪♪
♪ What did I see? ♪
♪ My two roommates
and one of their moms ♪
♪ No one invited me ♪
♪ Look, I'm trying
to shake it off ♪
♪ No bad blood for me ♪
-Whoo!
♪ 'Cause Taylor, Kelce, and me
makes three ♪
[ Laughter ]
♪ We just signed
a two-year lease ♪
♪ We got a month for free ♪
♪ Landlord says,
"You're lucky I'm a Swiftie" ♪
[ Laughter ]
♪ Travis showed me
his Super Bowl rings ♪
♪ Taylor showed me her Grammys ♪
♪ And I showed 'em videos
of my high-school dance team ♪
[ Laughter ]
♪ I knew you were trouble ♪
♪ But now we're a throuple ♪
[ Laughter ]
♪ That makes three ♪
♪ Taylor, Kelce, and me ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Josh Bolin!
That was fantastic!
Thank you, buddy.
You guys are so talented.
Oh, my gosh. In just an hour,
you guys rocked that out.
Now it's time to see who won,
so we're gonna let our great
audience decide the winner.
[ Audience murmuring ]
Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
Was it Rachel?
[ Cheers and applause ]
Or was it Josh?
[ Slightly louder
cheers and applause ]
We're gonna give it to Josh,
everybody! Congratulations!
Josh is the winner.
Guys, the winner --
the winner tonight goes home
with an "I Love Music"
sweatshirt.
Congratulations. Yeah.
Sorry you didn't win.
Oh, you also get --
you also get a notebook
for writing more songs.
And $1,000.
Hey, there you go, buddy.
Thank you. Congratulations.
-Thank you, Jimmy.
-But no one goes home
empty-handed.
Our other contestant
will get an "I Love Music"...
Come on.
You get a sweatshirt.
And a "Tonight Show" notebook
with $1,000!
Come on! Thank you for playing!
You were fantastic. Thank you.
Give it up for two new
Instant Song Writers.
Stick around. We'll be
right back with Maluma!